um what have you learned about board
meetings
uh and financing the ability to raise
money when a company does adopt
this well everything just gets a lot
more predictable
i mean that's really what you want is to
have um you know more
predictability um and you know you want
your your
board to weigh in when the
numbers are fresh right so you know if
you
if you don't do your board me if you do
your board meetings the same month two
or three of the quarter
then either you're further away from the
last
you know from the last uh fresh data so
you're two or three months away
so the data you have isn't as fresh or
um
you know or it's it's um rough estimates
yeah it's rough estimates you're you're
dealing with
say a half half bake quarter right and
so then you get the excuses oh maybe
it's actually we always do better
towards the last six weeks anything can
change or we're off to a strong start
but i don't know if it's going to keep
up right
it just becomes this sort of circular
madness
right um yeah exactly so and then this
the last piece of it
is is all hands meetings which you know
is a very important way especially as a
company gets bigger and bigger
for you to keep everyone coordinated is
to have you know a steady stream of all
hands meetings
and what the cadence does is give you
the topics for those meetings
so so immediately right after the end of
the quarterly close
i think it's a really good idea for the
ceo to go in front of the company and
explain how he just did
right like counting the numbers how did
we do exactly what were the sales
results okay
yeah then you're going to have a board
meeting and right after that i like
going in front of the company
and recapitulating the strategy of the
company right so
because board is your board means our
time to take a 30
000 foot view of the company and you
know think about your strategy so i like
the idea of after the board being you
present
that strategy to the board if it hasn't
changed in the last few months that's
fine there may be a lot of new
employees who need to hear the the
strategy of the company but maybe
there's some adjustments
that you're making you need to explain
that then you've got the launch event
coming up and what i like to do is i
like to put the product managers
in front of the company and you preview
what's gonna happen at that launch event
you tell people what's coming
okay and then after the launch event you
do a big
company-wide debrief how did it go you
know what was the reaction
you know the marketing department might
show press highlights
um you know it's but you basically do a
big
debrief and you feed those insights back
into the company
should all hands be monthly weekly or
every two weeks because i i you know
in the early days of google they were
doing weekly i think facebook i think
was doing it twice a month is there some
cadence to that that you buy into or is
it just the stylistic preference of the
founder um i think you know every two
weeks is fine i think you know weekly is
fine too
but um but i think that if you want to
do it as
frequently as weekly what i'd recommend
is that
every other all hands you get somebody
else in the company go up and present
got it so i think it's i think it's good
for the company to hear
you know especially as the company gets
bigger and bigger right you get this
compartmentalization people don't know
what's happening in other parts of the
company i think it's very useful
for people to hear from the engineering
leader the sales leader the
you know analytics leader and so on down
the line they can tell
the whole company what's happening in
their teams so
that's what i would do because i think
it gets to be a little bit much if the
founder ceos is getting up there every
single week yeah
you also you run out of things to say
therefore what you say is diluted
therefore you just sound like you're
droning on you know it just becomes too
much